[Musique]
comment et pourquoi été bâtis les
forteresses du moyen-âge symbole de la
féodalité et du pouvoir d'un homme
le seigneur comment expliquer la
floraison d'édifices quasiment identique
au xiième et xiiième siècle période
qualifiée d' âge d'or des châteaux forts
au milieu des années 1990 deux
passionnés d'histoire médiévale
michel guyot et maryline martin
conçoivent un projet fou qui permettrait
de répondre à ces questions longtemps
demeurait mystérieuse
l'enjeu était de taille il fallait
envisager des problèmes économiques
suscitée par une telle oeuvre retrouver
et refonder les corporations de métiers
engagé sur un tel chantier évalué la
durée de production comprendre le
maniement des outils et la
transformation des matériaux tout un
univers à extirper de l'oubli le projet
du château de guédelon était né en
recréant à partir de rien un édifice
magnifique
l'équipe a fait ressurgir du passé le
sens même de ce type de construction en
tentant cette aventure peu ordinaire
ils ont résolu bien des questions
comment les ouvriers du moyen-âge choisi
cette île leurs pierres avec l mortier
les ont-ils scellé entre elles
comment les transports et il est avec
quelle machine les i cette île à
plusieurs dizaines de mètres parfois
comment était établi les plans de ces
édifices
quels étaient les étapes d'une telle
construction
depuis plus de 20 ans les ratisseurs de
guédelon et leurs maîtres d'oeuvre
tendent la main à leurs ancêtres ils ont
débuté un voyage dans le temps
un périple à la rencontre d'un seigneur
imaginaire que leur travail a rendu
pireyre au coeur d'une forêt de
bourgogne
le château de guédelon se dresse tel une
porte vers le xiiie siècle un passage
magique
vers l'âge d'or des châteaux forts
au tournant de l'an mil les premiers
châteaux apparaissent ce ne sont d'abord
que des mottes castrales des tours de
bois symbole de la féodalité et du
pouvoir des seigneurs ses premiers
retours bâti sur un tertre artificiels
sont entourés d'une série de palissades
délimitant l'espace à défendre c'est à
l'intérieur de cette enceinte que vivent
les premiers seigneurs leur famille et
ceux qui la servent ces édifices de bois
rapides à construire jalonnent le
territoire mais ils ont un point faible
ils sont fragiles car peu résistant au
feu très vite les seniors les plus
fortunés font remplacer leur tour de
bois par une grande tour la tour
maîtresse siège du pouvoir féodal en
pierre cette fois l'édifice est au coeur
de la stratégie des puissants de
l'époque le château doit leur permettre
d'administrer et de défendre leurs
terres
si ce type de constructions se
multiplient au xième et xiième siècle
les modes castrale ne disparaissent pas
radicalement elle cohabite avec ces
nouveaux châteaux demeures d'hommes
capables de réunir les sommes
astronomiques nécessaires à leur
construction
entre le 10e et le xiiie siècle les
plans des châteaux sont très variables
il évolue selon que le seigneur
commanditaire de l ouvrage le fait
construire sur un piton rocheux jeu en
plaine ou dans le méandre d'une rivière
mais la logique d'implantation de ces
châteaux est toujours la même cette
évidence
l'équipe de guédelon en a fait
l'expérience dès le début de leur projet
débuté en 1998 le chantier du château de
guédelon s'étendra sur 25 ans ou xiiie
siècle une construction identiques
étaient généralement achevée en 12 ou 15
ans mais les commanditaires les plus
riches peuvent aller beaucoup plus vite
au moyen âge les bâtisseurs travaillent
en moyenne 200 jours par an huit heures
par jour en automne et en hiver et 12h
de pâques à septembre le samedi et les
veilles de jours fériés le travail
s'arrête hanon autour de 15h pour
construire vite et bien
les commanditaires et les maîtres
d'oeuvre du moyen-âge choisissez avec
soin le terrain sur lequel le château
allait être bâtie il fallait l'intégrer
à son environnement pour le construire à
moindre frais en utilisant des matériaux
disponibles rapidement
[Musique]
florian renucci est le maître d'oeuvre
de guédelon comme au moyen âge il doit
gérer les ressources locales résoudre
les problèmes techniques de réalisation
contrôle équipé utap du chantier est
respecté l'enveloppé financière qui lui
a été alloué un vrai défi pour toute
l'équipe car personne n'avait tenté
cette aventure depuis plusieurs siècles
c'est une logique on va récupérer les
matériaux sur un maximum de distance de
3 5 km et quand on a les matériaux sur
place c'est encore mieux
bien évidemment les bâtisseurs de
guédelon se sont donc enfoncé dans une
épaisse forêt
les chaînes pourraient fournir le bois
nécessaire à la fabrication des
charpentes des échafaudages et des
engins de levage
l'ol était partout est au coeur de ce
massif
ils ont découvert le graal de tout
constructeur de châteaufort une carrière
de pierres une fois entièrement terminés
le château aura absorbé 10 mille mètres
cubes de pierres soit 25000 tonnes
degrés le poids de 3 tours eiffel ou de
soixante et un boeing 747
[Musique]
à guédelon le château est directement
implanté sur une carrière de grès
ferrugineux c'est du sable qui était
collée par de l'oxydé de fer qui alliait
de locre et les sables forme des couches
sédimenter mais que l'on peut assez
facilement séparer signe roche qui
cliver et en utilisant la masse on
arrive à séparer les pierres qui vous
nous donner trois qualités
la première on la réserve aux blocs de
pierres de taille pour les rangs de
réalignement pour démarche de seuils de
portes
la deuxième jeu des pierres cassées vont
faire les moellons et les beauty ce
qu'ils sont les pierres qui sont sur le
devant du mur du château la troisième
qualité passé les chutes finalement
c'est tout ce qu'on va mettre à
l'intérieur du mur en remplissage les
carriers ont dû apprivoiser la pierre il
a fallu l'approché et la décrypter pour
la comprendre et l'utiliser de la
meilleure des manières
plus la pierre et bleu et plus elle sera
difficile à traiter
ils ont retrouvé la technique permettant
d'extraire les blocs
il faut faire des en voiture des
entailles dans les blocs à l'endroit où
les carriers souhaite que la roche rond
ils placent ensuite dé quoi métallique
et frappe dessus avec la masse pour que
l'ombre de choc rompent la pierre sous
forme de grandes plaques les tables
[Musique]
et des blogs qui peut faire entre 100 kg
et 3 4 tonnes et des fois sur des gros
blocs de cape town bas on va chercher le
la faiblesse voilà on va chercher la
faiblesse de chercher la strate et du
coup à partir de là bas juste et qu'un
coin on peut voit des blocs de quatre
tonnes est juste et 15 points sans trop
se fatiguer quoi
en effectuant des sondages de surface
dans les terrains alentours
les bâtisseurs ont découvert d'autres
trésors le sol de guédelon est composé
de glaise d'argile et de sable la glaise
terne surface permettra de façonner les
tuiles et les carreaux de pavement du
château l'argile terre plus profonde et
plus pur servira à fabriquer la
vaisselle le sable rentrera dans la
composition d'un produit est essentielle
à la construction
le mortier les bâtisseurs modernes ont
observé les enluminures et recréer les
outils spécifiques comme la ou a gâché
utilisées sur le chantier
mais encore fallait-il savoir comment le
mortier du moyen-âge été fabriqué une
enquête scientifique débuté pour
simplifier le mortier c'est l'alcool
c'est ce qui permet de sceller les
pierres dans le mortier il faut de la
chaux du sable et de l'eau or au départ
les premières années on utilisait un
match chaud industriel avec du sable qui
venait pas de la région mais sur le
comité scientifique a trouvé que le
rendu pierre mortier c'était pas ça et
là même qui s'appelle and go qui fait
partie du comité scientifique et
professeur à l'université bio elle nous
a fait rencontrer christian le barrier
qui est un spécialiste du mortier donc
il est venu sur chantier il a regardé
comment on travaillait pris le sable
qu'on avait sur place pour le mélanger
avec la chose faite de manière
artisanale et du coup on a obtenu un
mortier qui est pas le même qu'on
utilise avant et christian a été faire
des études comparatives au château de
ratification km d'ici au château de
saint fargeau
c'est une base aussi 13e et il s'est
aperçu que c'était la même composition
donc là on est vraiment dans le dos qui
se serait fait ici cette époque là
à guédelon tous les matériaux de base
sont sur place y compris le faire
l'aventuré humaine du chantier a
consisté à aller plus loin dans la
transformation de matériaux et la pierre
de la carrière contient suffisamment
d'oxydé de fer pour pouvoir récolter ce
minerai et les forgerons deviennent
ferron et plusieurs fois dans l'année
ils font des réductions se dire qu'ils
vont chauffer cette pierre à 1400 degrés
pour obtenir du fer et de l'acier
la réduction de plus de 20 kg de minerai
permet d'obtenir environ un kilo et demi
de métal tester aussitôt par les
forgerons
on a une partie
très dense c'est c'est forcément du
métal donc le fait de leur passé dans la
force après nous permettre de le
travailler correctement
un peu de faire passer
après l'objectif c'est de le travail et
de voir comment il se comporte au
travail est ce qu'on va pouvoir
l'utiliser par la suite pour faire soit
de la ferronnerie soit des outils pour
la construction du château au xiième et
xiiième siècle les forges prennent de
l'ampleur grâce notamment à l' usage de
l'énergie hydraulique à guédelon tous
les outils métalliques sont façonnés sur
place et tous les jours les forgerons
prennent en charge l'entretien de
l'outillage notamment celui des
tailleurs de pierre soumis à rude
épreuve
[Musique]
le chantier se situe également au coeur
d'une autre source d'approvisionnement
essentielle aux travaux la forêt la
forêt de guînes l'ong a fourni
nombreuses essences de bois dont en
particulier le chêne qui est l'essence
la plus employée sur le chantier on peut
lire plus de 82%
elle va s'en servir notamment pour faire
toutes les pièces de charpente pour
faire les portes pour faire tous les
éléments de bois qui sont défensif et à
côté on va trouver d'autres essences
comme le hêtre le charme les alisiers
tous et voilà en fait qui vont servir
faire différentes pièces beaucoup plus
petit en drainage de moulins mange
l'outil et on va trouver des essences
encore plus petites comme losier qui va
servir à faire tout lehman pour
transporter le mortier d'autres choses
on a des morceaux de bois
défragmentation de bois qui ont été
retrouvés dans des fouilles qui nous
prouve donc là on peut pas le remettre
en cause
on est sûr que tout les charpentes de la
période médiévale et même la plus tard
sont en chêne ça c'est irréfutable
les charpentiers ont monté les ateliers
les loges
il travaille en étroite coopération avec
le maître d'oeuvre
les maçons les tailleurs de pierre et
les forgerons il réalise les brouettes
les gammes apte pour le mortier les
échafaudages
les poutres maîtresses du logis les
charpentes à chevrons la forêt qui
entoure le château fournit également le
bois utile à la fabrication des
tavaillons les tuiles en bois parfois
munis de celui de fixation qui seront
stockés avant d'être posée c'est tout un
écosystème qui se transforme mon château
dont tous les matériaux de manière
raisonnée vont devenir des matériaux de
construction si bien pour le gros oeuvre
que pour les finitions
si l'implantation des châteaux suis
toujours la même logique depuis l'an mil
protéger un seigneur et défendre
territoire les édifices bâtis au xiiie
siècle résulte des mutations politiques
économiques et culturelles de leur
époque
[Musique]
au cours du 12e siècle l'amélioration
des rendements agricoles entraîne une
modification des conditions de vie d'une
partie de la population
certains paysans quittent leur campagne
pour rejoindre les villes en plein essor
ce nouveau peuple débours rejoint les
rangs d'un artisanat de plus en plus
florissant et fournit une main d'oeuvre
de plus en plus qualifiés au millier de
chantiers qui s'ouvrent à la même époque
les ouvriers se spécialise forgeron
maçons tailleurs de pierre charpentier
gâcheur élus seront les communes
deviennent des centres de décision
indépendante affranchie de la tutelle
des seigneurs et de l'église
les plus grandes cités développe le
commerce et facilite les échanges entre
région en organisant des foires et des
marchés
peu à peu elle s'émancipe du pouvoir
féodal traditionnels
au moins de juin 12 104 philippe auguste
7e roi de la dynastie des capétiens est
désigné roi de france et non plus roi
des francs une nation est en gestation
le nouveau souverain néant 165 va
rétablir son influence dans toutes les
provinces tenus par les grands vassaux
et étendre considérablement le
territoire royal entre 299 et 12114
philippe auguste se lance dans de
grandes expéditions de reconquête du
territoire français au nord il reprend
l'artois le boulonnais levallois et le
vermandois
à l'ouest il rattache le vexin normand
la normandie la bretagne le maine le
poitou la touraine et l'anjou au centre
ils annexent le berry et l'auvergne et
enfin à l'est
il récupère la champagne sur ces
nouvelles conquêtes
philippe auguste nomme des serviteurs de
l'état rigoureusement indépendant de la
noblesse des baillis des prévôts baisser
les shows et surtout pour défendre ces
territoires et les garder au sein de la
couronne il va faire construire un
nombre considérable de châteaux forts
dont le plan et standardisée pour
maîtriser les coûts
le modèle initial se trouve à paris
avant de partir pour la troisième
croisade en 195 philippe auguste veut
protéger la ville à l'ouest
il fait édifier une puissante forteresse
le louvre les troupes aguerries qui sont
stationnés peuvent faire face à
d'éventuels assaillants qui
remonteraient la scène ils peuvent aussi
barré la route menant à la normandie à
leurs aux mains de richard 1er
d'angleterre dit coeur de lion l'édifice
format carré de 70 m de côté flanqué de
10 tours circulaire une à chaque angle
une au milieu des côtes est ouest et
nord au centre des côtés sud est est des
tours jumelles encadre la porte au
milieu de la cour s'élève le donjon
posée sur un socle cylindrique haut de 6
mètres
[Musique]
cette tour maîtresse de 15 mètres de
diamètre s'élève à une hauteur de 30
mètres
ces murs ont environ quatre mètres
d'épaisseur dans la cour adossées au
flanc ouest et sud s'élève les logis de
la garnison
le louvre est le rempart qui entourent
paris inspireront les plans d'une
multitude de châteaux forts construits
ou remaniés entre douce en deux et douce
en vain
mais c'est le château royal de dourdan
qui sera le modèle standard pour les
fortifications commandé par les
successeurs de philippe auguste son fils
louis 8 et son petit fils louis 9 10
saint louis
[Musique]
la provence et le comté de toulouse ont
alors intégrer le royaume louis 9 va
unifier et consolider l'héritage sous
son règne entre 226 et 12 170 il
poursuit l'idéal capétiens d'un état qui
s'étendrait de brest à strasbourg et de
lille à aigues-mortes
dès le milieu du 12e siècle et au cours
du xiiie siècle 80 cathédrale
jaillissent de terre dans le royaume de
france
l' architecture gothique évolué elle
parvient à des degrés de complexité
telle qu'elle réclame une incroyable
maîtrise technique sur les grands
chantiers les maîtres d'oeuvre se
croisent et échangent leurs
connaissances
mais comment les bâtisseurs de guédelon
ont-ils définit les méthodes de
construction les sources dont on dispose
pour construire un château du premier
tiers milieu 13e sont bien sûr les
châteaux donc on a bien sûr ratti juste
à côté qui nous a donné le modèle d'une
l'utilisation du grès ferrugineux et la
manière de l'utiliser dans une culture
constructive locale on a aussi les
comptes de chantier les comptes de
druelle et bellefontaine nous font part
du type de toiture utiliser et troisième
source importante évidemment dont on a
tiré toute la vie quotidienne les
enluminures donc des dessins de chantier
une 11ème 13ème 14ème siècle qui aurait
pu construire un moyen seigneur le
résultat de cet énorme travail de
recherche est saisissant
sous nos yeux s'anime soudain les
personnages des enluminures et des
vitraux du moyen âge le chantier
fourmillent les ouvriers sont là les
tailleurs de pierre sous leurs apprentis
de boire les bûcherons et carissan les
troncs fraîchement coupé les gachères
préparant le mortier
les mâts sont juchés sur les
échafaudages et montante a sciemment
lire les outils sont identiques
tout comme les engins de levage ou les
moyens de transport dès le début
certaines évidences se sont imposés aux
bâtisseurs démarrage du chantier on
avait des gammes à tdc extrêmement lourd
donc déjà il peser leur poids et quand
on les remplit ses de mortier c'était
ingérable et on s'est rendu compte que
toutes les zones minières mais aussi les
vitraux représentent en fait des mânes
ce d'espèces de contenants avec des ans
donc c'est de l'osier clic et tressés et
qui permet effectivement de ne porter
que le poids du mortier donc le chantier
a créé un atelier de tressage d'osier et
toutes les manoeuvres de maçon
maintenant utilisent bien évidemment des
mânes beaucoup plus légère et en raccord
avec qui à une prévente les enluminures
au moyen âge le rôle des maîtres
d'oeuvre est primordial ce sont les
garants de l'équilibré des forces
impliquées dans la construction les
maçonneries toujours plus haute
élaborer les arcs de plus en plus
élancée les voûtes sur lesquels reposent
des tonnes de pierres
ici pourtant pas de plomb sur parchemin
dans la chambre d'être est le maître
d'oeuvre trace les épures des dessins à
l'échelle 1 de l'ouvragé à réaliser il
fournit aux tailleurs de pierre et aux
charpentiers des gabarits qui leur
permettent de suivre ses instructions et
de réaliser les ouvrages 6 en fait tu
vois c'est assistance là qui pourrait
diviser cette en étant précis au
millimètre sur les purs
ça permet d'avoir les pierres les plus
faibles à bhl les plus parfaite possible
à la taille
[Musique]
le cad review mkii et l'enseignement mis
en place par charlemagne
c'est l'enseignement de la géométrie est
essentiellement de la géométrie grecque
les éléments d'euclide pythagore son
enseigne et donc ils maîtrisent au
niveau géométrie la totalité de la
géométrie plane telle qu'elle est
enseignée aujourd'hui en primaire et au
collège
en fait le monde médiéval et
pragmatiques ils ont utilisé les
connaissances de l'antiquité pour faire
fonctionner leurs sociétés
[Musique]
il faudra attendre la fin du moyen-âge
pour voir apparaître les plans à échelle
réduite tels que nous les connaissons
aujourd'hui
entre temps les maîtres d'oeuvre auront
atteint une telle maîtrise qu ils seront
devenus plus que de simples
entrepreneurs locaux de véritables
architectes la bibliothèque nationale de
france conserve un vrai trésor
les carnets de villard de honnecourt un
maître d'oeuvre née au début du xiiie
siècle près de cambrai au cours de son
apprentissage
l'homme va de chantier en chantier et de
ville en ville c'est écrit relate une
partie de son périple il est d'abord à
vaucelles près de cambrai où il
travaille à la construction de l'abbaye
cistercienne puis à reims laon jardres
lausanne et vers 12 134
ils participent à l'édification d'une
cathédrale à coacher en hongrie
ces pages par cheminées contiennent des
planches naturalistes des
représentations de personnages dont un
autoportrait de l'auteur en guerrier il
renferme aussi des allégories et des
scènes religieuses 74 dessins sur les
250 concerne l'architecturé des études
géométrique mais honnecourt a aussi
dessiné des engins de levage et des
machines militaire car l'art de
construire des châteaux forts est alors
indissociable de celui de la guerre le
haut moyen âge aux 10e et 11e siècle
ignore tout des machines de guerres
anciennes et pour cause les premières
fortifications de pierre faisait souvent
face à de petites troupes de fantassins
et de cavaliers
mais au cours des croisades des 12e et
13e siècles les combattants francs ont
dû ressusciter les machines de guerre
afin de s'emparer des villes fortifiées
ils ont donc ramené dans leurs bagages
les plans et les maquettes de ces engins
redoutable tour mobile pour être à
hauteur des murailles à prendre d'assaut
ailier shout aux mentonnais
l'armée royale lost regroupe désormais
des centaines voire des milliers
d'hommes au xiième et xiiième siècle
l'attak prend le pas sur la défense
les souverains utilise alors les
services d'un ou plusieurs ingénieurs
souvent des clercs féru de littérature
antique qui ont re découvert les engins
de guerre onagre catapulte et autres
analystes
en lisant les écrits d'archimède de
vitruve devait ges ou damien marcellin
les engins transportait par chariot en
pièces détachées sont généralement des
machines de jets des pierres hier à
contrepoids capable de lancer des boules
est de 12 kg à 175 mètres de distance
avec une marge d'erreur de quelques
mètres seulement pour faire face à ces
nouveaux périls l'architecturé des
châteaux devait être considérablement
adapté au cours du 3ème siècle les tours
de bois vulnérables aux jets des
machines de guerre disparaissent pour
être remplacées par des constructions en
encorbellement les bretèche un petit
avant corps rectangulaire ou à pans
coupés et les mâchicoulis une galerie de
pierre courant sur le sommet des
courtines les progrès dans l'art de
construire rendent les fortifications
encore plus solide et difficile à
approcher les châteaux construits en
pleine repose sur impuissante à lui de
pierre
les écarte alors dans les premières
années il a fallu commencer par bâtir le
socle du château donc toute la base avec
ses murs en pente
c'est plus de 250 mètres linaires
développer représentant à peu près trois
mille mètres cubes et ça nous a pris
quatre ans à guédelon les esclaves des
six tours et des courtines représente
3000 mètres cubes de pierres soit
environ 6000 tonnes
la longueur des murs est impressionnante
à la fin du chantier les maçons auront
bâti 250 m de courtine un travail
colossal allait vraiment se soutenir les
dix dernières pierres ont fait envoyer
des messages tailleur de pierre masson
c'est l'avant avant derrière qui c'est
la dernière et pour enfin atteindre
partout au niveau du socle du château
cette ligne on allait enfin pouvoir
démarrer le mur vertical mais en même
temps c'était se remettre dans la grande
lignée des bâtisseurs puisque
les enceintes urbaine tous les châteaux
xiiie siècle font passer par ce travail
harassant de fortifications en talus
l'étude des murs médiévaux permet de
restituer toutes les étapes de
maçonnerie le mur est bâtie en couches
de pierre successives à la manière d'un
millefeuille la maçonnerie de moellons
les pierres non taillés alterne tous les
trois mètres environ par trois niveaux 3
à 6 de pierres de taille c'est le rang
de réalignement les murailles comporte
aussi à espace régulier des trous d'un
usage est longtemps demeurée un mystère
ce sont les trous des boulin ses longues
poutres de chêne encre et jusqu'à un
mètre dans l'épaisseur du mur est
destiné à supporter les plateaux
d'échafaudages les charpentiers les
remonte au fur et à mesure de la
construction
chaque rang de boulin est espacée de 1 m
40 hauteur idéale pour le travail des
maçons et des tailleurs de pierre après
usage les trous sont généralement
comblés avec des bouchons de pierre
engrais qui peuvent être ôtés en cas de
restauration du bâtiment
les échafaudages rythme donc la
construction de châteaux dont les murs
sont de plus en plus
pour monter les matériaux à plus de 10
mètres parfois les charpentiers de
guédelon disposent d'engins de levage
les cage à écureuil qu'il a fallu
reconstituer pour fabriquer ses cages
écureuils médiévale on bénéficie de cash
& carry existantes qui ont été relevés
dans la cathédrale de strasbourg de
canterbury en angleterre ou de bourges
comme celle ci ou à double tambour
notamment celle de la bible devient
esclave 4 qui est conservé à prague et
qui nous présente une cage et coeur avec
complète avec son système de cordes et
de poulies nous les cages écureuils on
s'en sert évidemment quotidiennement à
gueugnon
on travaille avec une cage double
tambour deux personnes marchent dans la
rue pour actionner une corde et lever
les charges soient dumortier soit de la
pierre on a la chance d'avoir une cage
qui est sur un axe qui nous permet de
disposer les chargeurs 360° et moi tout
moment je peux arrêter la manoeuvre
houle a démarré à l'aide du frein
centrale ici les deux patins j'ai ici
qui actionne ou qu'ils arrêtent la roue
cet ancêtre de la grue permet de monter
à 15 mètres de hauteur des charges
pouvant aller jusqu'à 600 kg les cage à
écureuil peuvent être démontés et
replacer à n'importe quel endroit du
chantier y compris tout en haut des
murailles super garder le contact
il ya aussi des réflexes constructif qui
nous aident à faire nos manoeuvres par
exemple les murs sont construits par
couche de pierre parrat raju le mur
d'une couche à l'autre est parfaitement
horizontal ce qui permet de pouvoir
utiliser le mur par lui-même comme
stratégie qui entre la construction de
faire circuler la pierre sur des rôles
jusqu'à son emplacement où elle sera
scellé avec l' architecture philippe
yens et notamment les châteaux du louvre
et de dourdan la défense devient active
la masse de pierre n'est plus la seule
composante défensive du bâtiment il est
désormais conçue pour frapper
l'assiégeant autant que pour l'empêcher
de franchir la muraille au xiiie siècle
les constructions sont de plus en plus
élaborées l' architecture se tournant
résolument vers la défense active du
château
les forces actives telle qu'elle est
réinventée par philippe auguste
au début xiiie c'est l'addition en fait
de fausses et de schumann ronde avec
portes entre deux tours et bien sûr tour
maîtresse alors au niveau des courtines
qui font la totalité de la périphérie du
château font à peu près 1 m 52 de
largeur pour se déplacer des murs par ap
d'une cinquantaine de centimètres
d'épaisseur avec des créneaux et des
merlons hauteur moyenne de m c'est ce
qui permet effectivement de défendre le
château par le haut on se protège au
niveau des merlons et en envoyant des
pierres ou en tirant avec arc war balle
est philippe but va générer vidéos
courtes son règne l'utilisation de la
couronne pour flanquer un angle de
châteaux alors il la vend pas cette
forme qui existe depuis le monde romain
et même au 12e siècle mais il va lui
apporter une évolution majeure
il va utiliser des archères donc il va
percer ses tours circulaire par des
archères permettant un tir flanquant et
un tir circulaire la rotondité permet
aussi à ces tours d'être moins
vulnérable aux attaques des engins qui
jettent des pierres donc moins
vulnérables que les troupes car et c'est
pour ça que à partir des années douces
on sait cette formule de château à tour
ronde qui s'impose dans le monde
capétiens
mais comment les maîtres d'oeuvre
médiévaux parvenait il a tracé des tours
parfaitement ondes des normes qu'on pas
équipé d'un mât et d'une perche
horizontales sont fabriqués puis
installé au centre des tours
lorsque le compas tourner le fil à plomb
attaché à la perche décrit un cercle
parfait
désormais les châteaux sont de mieux en
mieux préparés aux éventuelles attaques
les fossés qui les entourent sont de
plus en plus profond 12 m à dourdan 22 m
à coucy la porte
entre deux tours est infranchissable
munis de hertz des grilles de bois bardé
de faire
les murs garni de créneaux et d'un
chemin de ronde continue sont rythmées
par des tours engagé et détours flanc
quand tu perds cedar chers dont le champ
de tir et soigneusement calculés alors
là on trouve dans la salle de tir du
rez-de-chaussée de la tour maîtresse
les murs ont une épaisseur de plus de 3
mètres ce qui correspond à peu de choses
près au rayon de la salle qui fait donc
un diamètre de 6 m et cette pièce est
équipé de cinq arches r dc les archers
tirent depuis la salle
pas question d'entrer dans la recherche
d'autant plus qu'elles sont plongeante
ce qui permet de tirer jusqu'en bas des
murs
[Musique]
chantal porte et championne du monde de
tir à l'arc sur cible en trois
dimensions elle a accepté de faire une
petite expérience
on a placé une cible sur le pont un qui
est à peu près à l'est où une quinzaine
de mètres et la question se pose est-ce
qu'on va arriver à avoir une flèche qui
passent haut la main dans la fente d'art
cher qui ne fait que
7 cm et est ce qu'on va arriver à avoir
une amplitude de tir plus large et
arrosé sur 10 ou 15 mètres de largeur de
vent je ne sais pas parce que j'ai
jamais terrer dans ce genre de situation
c'est une première on va déjà essayer
tout droit parce que du coup ça me fait
un petit peu peur c'est cette nuit sont
immédiats et puis après ben si tout va
bien on essaiera cette amplitude voir ce
qu'on peut faire
aulas lors c'est magnifique bravo donc
cela veut dire ça fonctionne ça pose là
dans laxe c'est impeccable
alors on va essayer maintenant plus
délicat savoir si on peut tirer
parallèle ah les braves gens si on peut
amplifier l'amplitude de tir en
extérieur
la cible est à présent déplacer d'une
dizaine de mètres sur le côté
parfaitement dans le mille
j'étais un peu sceptique à mais je pense
qu'on peut faire confiance aux gens du
moyen-âge les avait déjà testé la chose
et je pense qu'ils avaient vu juste
ça veut dire qu'avec 7 cm d'ouverture de
recherche avec une largeur d'un mètre
vingt
on peut couvrir sur le devant un champ
de plus de 10 mètres ça veut dire qu'il
pourrait même être plusieurs archers
attirer le château fort protègent les
terres qu'il domine sa garnison juchés
sur les murailles ou retranchés dans le
corps de garde et les tours peut
défendre activement la passe et infligé
des pertes sévères à l'ennemi qui osent
l'attaqué
sur dessus une fois été chargé l'attend
ce
l'efficacité de l'architecturé philippe
yen est telle que les châteaux peuvent
désormais être bâtie en plein ou à fond
de vallée
plus besoin de les construire sur des
hauteurs au xiiie siècle le château fort
évolué dans ses formes
le renouveau des villes avec leurs
palais épiscopal les hôtels des grands
seigneurs les belles demeures d'une
bourgeoisie de plus en plus influente
inspirent les seigneurs le souci de
confort et la recherche de lumière
l'emportent d'ailleurs l'enceinte est si
puissante que la tour maîtresse
disparaît parfois elles se déplacent
généralement dans l'un des angles pour
laisser la place au logis construit dans
la cour intérieure appuyez sur l'un des
murs d'enceinte comme à guédelon à
partir du moment où les châteaux
s'organise autour de court lors formant
une carapace les façades qui donne sur
la cour n'ont pas besoin effectivement
d'être surprotéger défensives comme
c'était le cas des petites fenêtres des
donjons la période précédente 11e 12e
donc du coup on commence à ouvrir sur
les logis des des fenêtres alors le
style cdb géminées de ce milieu 13e le
pouvoir décorative de ses fenêtres tiens
à leur composition
elles sont constituées de deux
ouvertures rectangulaire avec un mono
centrale les piédroits soutiennent un
arc brisé qui déchargent les linteaux en
formant un tympan les linteaux au dessus
des ouvertures sont refouiller de tri
loeb
l'ensemble de ces éléments habille la
façade plus que ne le ferait de simples
linteau alors que l'ouverture reste de
même dimension
à l'intérieur dans la largeur du mur des
assises de pierres de taille un peu les
coûts sièges permettent aux occupants du
château de profiter pleinement de la
lumière du jour
[Musique]
il ya une volonté en fait de donner au
château un aspect ostentatoire un aspect
décoré pour souligner le caractère de la
puissance économique du seigneur et de
donner un statut à sa demeure
[Musique]
le château est donc bien plus qu'un
simple instrument de défense
il est la résidence et le lieu
d'exercice du pouvoir politique et
administrative du seigneur membres d'une
pyramide dont le sommet est occupé par
un seul homme le roi
[Musique]
ans
l'important c'est l' architecture de
chaque places fortes sont donc
déterminés par le statut social du
commanditaire qui l'occupera au nom du
souverain le seigneur exerce sur son
fief le droit de ben l'autorisant à
prélever revenus directs et indirects au
xiiie siècle des personnages modestes se
taillent des fiefs grâce à leur bravoure
au combat ou plus simplement par mariage
et héritage le seigneur de guédelon
possède les droits de moyenne et basse
justice sa fonction et son rang
détermine larchitecture de son logis
outre les éléments défensifs le mur
d'enceinte les tours de flottement la
tour maîtresse on celle de la chapelle
le château possède un imposant logis
seigneurial comprenant au rez de
chaussée une cuisine et un cellier à
laitages une grande salle la ola à
laquelle on accède par un grand escalier
alors cet escalier est ce qu'on appelle
un grand degré c'est pas simplement un
escalier fonctionnel il a un rôle
symbolique il va illustrer le pouvoir de
justice sociale c'est au pied de cet
escalier sur une grande marche de
pierres qu'on appelle le perron que le
seigneur rend sa sentence
les seniors les plus modestes ne dispose
que des droits de moyenne et basse
justice arbitrant des conflits entre
paysans constations sur des délits
mineurs
les grands seigneurs eux exercent les
droits étendus à la haute justice et
peuvent prononcer toutes les peines y
compris la peine capitale
les droits banos qui font associés aux
territoires impose tout un tas de règles
assez incroyable il y à des territoires
qui sont réservées aux villageois
d'autres réservés aux seniors donc
effectivement récupérer un lapin abattre
un arbre sur un territoire réservé c'est
s'exposer bien sûr à la vindicte
seigneurial donc escaliers c'est bel et
bien le symbole de ce pouvoir
seigneurial
alors la vraie dans la grande salle
appelez-la aux larmes c'est un espace
public du château qui s'opposent aux
parties privatives réservé aux seniors
et à sa famille dans cette grande salle
on peut dresser des tréteaux pour les
banques et peut dresser une estrade pour
édicter certains jugements
c'est une salle polyvalente
[Musique]
c'est aussi ici que se déroulent les
grandes cérémonies de la vie féodal
comme l'hommage par lequel un homme
libre se place sous la protection d'un
autre homme libre plus puissants sont
sus à l'hommage c'est quand un seigneur
important va octroyer un territoire en
échange de sa fidélité à un vassal et
cette cérémonie est accompagné par un
rituel qui va finalement regroupés ce
monde d bellator de la noblesse
donc le banquier les ménestrels tout
cela est une codification la chasse
pendant plusieurs jours s'est partagé
les mêmes rites pour faire corps d'une
société qui a quand même pour essence de
ne pas se mélanger
ni avec les religieux ni avec les
paysans le statut du noble occupant le
château exige une vie sociale qui se
déroule dans sa grande salle la ola est
donc le lieu des banquets des fêtes
on y danse on y veille très tard en se
racontant des récits guerriers ou en
commentant l'actualité politique
donc cette salle en tant que lieu de
pouvoir est au coeur même de la
symbolique de la société féodale
[Musique]
à la fin des soirées les hôtes de marque
sont accueillis au château
ils dorment dans une chambre contiguë à
la grande salle les murs ont été décorés
avec soin en s'inspirant de peinture
trouvaient dans des logiciels muriaux ou
des églises toutes proches comme celle
de moûtiers
pour embellir les parois zostères de
cette pièce l'équipe de guédelon a
utilisé une très vieille technique la
détrempe à la chaux en utilisant les
pigments prélevés sur place les ocres de
puisaye d'un enduit à la chaux qui va
être recouvert d'un badigeon avec un air
chaud qui va faire la surface blanche le
fond blanc sur lequel on va appliquer la
peinture saison due à la chaux vont
réguler les gros mais tri ils vont être
respirant donc absorber l'excès
d'humidité
on prend des offres du chantier ceux qui
sont préparés à l'atelier et on va faire
ce qu'on appelle une peinture à la
détrempe con non pas sur un enduit c'est
qu'il faut apporter d'émile ans pour que
ça tienne longtemps donc on va mettre de
l'oeuf un oeuf entier battus en omelette
et on va rajouter de la colle de peau
d'animal parce que dans la peau des
animaux il ya du collage être est ce
mélange va relativement peu ses cahiers
et la couleur bon on a envie on en a
besoin et puis ça sert aussi à montrer
qu'on a les moyens de le faire donc plus
les moyens les commanditaires seront
importants plus on aura un décor et
labouré qui va couvrir plus de surface
on va trouver partout cette frise de
triangle on va trouver l'ombre en
plissée qui existe déjà depuis plusieurs
siècles
et donc ces arbres ou ses vignes qui
sont
tout à fait locaux et ça fait un décor
qui est
mouvement beaucoup de vos luttes très
doux si l'on va retrouver dans toutes
les peintures murales de la région
la chambre du couple seigneurial de
guédelon sera situé au dernier étage de
la tour maîtresse encore en construction
mais la chambre du premier étage possède
déjà tous les éléments un espace
résidentiel une cheminée des latrines
des archères pour défendre la place mais
également une fenêtre donnant sur la
cour ces deux chambres sont au coeur
d'un véritable petit bastion l'accès de
la tour est protégée à l'extérieur par
le ur et à l'intérieur par un assommoir
protégeant la porte de l'escalier
rampant la salle basse comprend un puits
qui rend la tour maîtresse totalement
indépendant dans nos lots est primordial
dans un château fort parce qu'il faut
déjà tenir
être indépendant en eau lors d'un piège
mais elle sert aussi pour la vie
quotidienne et évidemment pour
construire le château fort alors à geel
on est accusé l'eau n'est jamais très
loin
on a creusé à 7 mètres de profondeur et
la particularité du puy c'est que à
cette époque on avait des bancs de grès
ferrugineux tout à fait homogène et est
assez grand pour contenir une margelle
monolithe c'est à dire que la margelle
dupuis est fait en un seul morceau qui a
été évident et par deux tailleurs de
pierres pendant un mois et demi c'est un
signe extérieur de richesse mais le
seigneur de guédelon on peut imaginer
qu'il s'est permis ce petit luxe parce
que la carrière lui a permis c'est
actuellement un des petits
chefs-d'oeuvre de la cour du château
à guédelon l'eau et donc stocké par tous
les citernes de la tour de la chapelle
et de la tour maîtresse la recueille par
capillarité le château peut tenir un
siège sans être obligé d'aller se
ravitailler ailleurs cette autonomie de
la place-forte est d'ailleurs renforcée
par l'autre pièce importante après la
grande salle le sellier le scellier est
le coeur de l'économie d'un château d'un
fief le rôle des seigneurs et
d'administrer le territoire et pour cela
il va collecter les impôts directs ou
indirects qui vont constituer les
revenus des droits banos des droits de
ben c'est pas forcément sous forme de
numéraire c'est sous forme de sacs de
grains de sacs de farine donc le
scellier c'est l'équivalent en va du
trésor public de la perception mais
concentrés dans la salle une des salles
du château dévolu à cet usage
le seigneur de guédelon et le maître
d'un fief dont l'exploitation lui
rapporte des revenus conséquents
le château fort n'est donc pas qu'un
camp militaire il anime économiquement
toute une région
sur ses terres le châtelain a fait
construire un four à tuiles et un moulin
[Musique]
l'exercice du droit de ben et de justice
sont autant de sources de revenus perçus
généralement sous forme de denrées
alimentaires précieusement entreposés
dans le cellier comme il y a beaucoup de
farine de sacs de grains il va falloir
empêcher les rongeurs les oiseaux
d'entrée donc le sellier se reconnaît à
des figures de porte
c'est à dire des retailles de
refoulement qui fait que quand on ferme
la porte elle est hermétiquement closes
y compris au niveau des seuils
pareil pour les soupiraux qui doivent
empêcher les oiseaux on y mettra des
volets de bois
les murs ont besoin d'être sain aussi
donc ils seront garnies d'ennuis et pète
je né à la chaux évidemment des étagères
vous garnir l'ensemble des murs avec
parfois des registres qui viennent
consignés tous que le sellier aura reçu
constituer les réserves du château est
un travail considérable
le seigneur préfère donc recevoir les
redevances de ces paysans en nature il
faut rentrer les grains presser les
raisins salé ou fumer les viandes ou les
poissons pêchés dans les étangs du fief
et surtout cuire le pain khl dont les
gens du moyen-âge mange un kilo par jour
[Musique]
après un lavage des mains très soigneux
le seigneur et sam et sni les gens du
château se met à table
[Musique]
dans un coin quelques musiciens de
passage un troubadour déclamant des vers
au xiiie siècle lors du carême le repas
du seigneur de guédelon est constitué de
quatre ou cinq plats de poisson du
brochet des carpes pêchées dans les
étangs alentours mais un vrai repas
comprend forcément de la viande du
gibier
il est le seul à pouvoir chasser sur ses
terres
cette viande est bouilli ou rôti
accompagnées de sauces froides ou
chaudes fortement épicé d'assez peu de
légumes verts sauf au printemps
[Musique]
les mains sont particulièrement loue
aussi les convives
doivent-ils de la pommade du cidre du
houblon fermenté ou de l'eau avec de la
réglisse ou du miel
le vin a bien sûr la préférence des
seniors les plus fortunés qui le font
venir à grands frais lorsque leur
domaine n'en produisent pas
ces repas peuvent durer des heures
animant ainsi le coeur d'une forteresse
dressée pour se défendre des méfaits de
la guerre et où la vie est parfois
longues à ses côtés
il permet aussi de souder les membres de
l'année sni et les clients les affidés
des proches entièrement dévoué au
seigneur le château se transforme alors
en un écrin celui du pouvoir d'un homme
et de sa famille
[Musique]
l'âge d'or des châteaux forts n'a pas
seulement consacré des avancées
architectural et une somme de progrès
technologique
il incarne la naissance d'un état jusqu
alors en gestation et la structuration
des campagnes et des villes
bientôt la puissance des seigneurs
féodaux déclinera au rythme du
renforcement du pouvoir des rois les
châteaux suivront alors le destin de
leurs commanditaires
le château de guédelon n'est pas qu'une
forteresse de plus posé dans le paysage
la construction fait sens est le message
qu elle susurre à nos oreilles a
traversé les âges
comme si les ouvriers moderne avait en
plus des gestes et des techniques
ressusciter la portée symbolique de
l'édifice l'exploit de l'équipe du
projet guédelon est unique chaque pierre
posée chaque élément d'architecturé ou
de décors sont autant de souvenirs des
femmes et des hommes passait sur le
chantier
[Musique]
l'oeuvre tiendra à travers les
millénaires comme une trace des vies un
temps a semblé pour l'accomplir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
non
[Musique]